un fast-food oui mais haut de gamme
la recette a été concoctée par antoine
westermann chef multi étoilé de
strasbourg il s'est inspiré des méthodes
de la restauration rapide sauf pour la
recette des tartines au caviar
d'aubergine et méline ans c'est
l'ouverture aujourd'hui alors rien ne
doit être laissé au hasard
j'en estermann à l'oeil à tout et pour
ses sandwichs il a aussi une recette
secrète à part dont trois étoiles au
michelin
la monf usine un niveau qui est le
niveau ii des jours de fête quoi la
cuisson d'exception qui est faire une
cuisine simple à des prix attractifs
moi je pense que les deux les deux
choses vont de pair au commencement on a
démarré sur un constat qui était est il
possible de manger correctement à toute
heure de la journée
on en a conclu que non sur cynthia
essayons d'adapter le savoir faire d'un
chef à la restauration de tous les
instants
ici on mise avant tout sur la qualité
des produits et l'originalité des
recettes dans ce fast food de luxe leur
part beaucoup train dans les 8 euros en
moyenne